what's one thing more interesting than
watching professional league of legends
well it's the weekly mic checks that
Riot Games releases that gives us a look
at the inner workings of our favorite
teams sure it's interesting to hear
about the team's comms and strats but
let's be honest it's much more
interesting to see the pros mess around
so here's our picks for the top ten mic
checks and lull history how much do you
guys wanna bet that these guys just got
lucky that's the only reason that
they're here yeah yeah I don't think
that's a good way to think that
hilarious exchange combined with bio
frost being a stone-cold killer I'm
gonna flash and Lucia okay I'll bet for
it earns this mic check from the 2017
Summer Finals number 10 on the list how
many times can you say Jax in four
minutes and 26 seconds quite a bit as it
turns out in our number 9 pick this mic
check from c9 vs CLG during the 2016
spring split otherwise this is a great
look into highs legendary shotcalling
and clg's team coordination codex
[Music]
that's accents
I'm turning it up
run that's fine we got the man just push
the weights are putting them all
good
yeah
in our number eight pick we have the
2017 MSI grand finals with g2 vs. SKT
no pain no pain when the kings of Europe
face the gods of the world no one really
expected them to have a chance not even
g2 themselves today we can prove that we
are the best dick in the world
we can also prove over the second
question in a row we can also prove were
not the second question this is a great
chance to get a glimpse into the
masterful play of SKT okay okay wait you
got it all as well as g2 s focal
enthusiasm and sense of humor
[Music]
I relive the glory days at number seven
with this mic check from 2015
that's all liquid take on Team impulse
please carry me rush yeah alright please
carry me too yeah I don't need you
featuring famous [ __ ] talker I will
dominate before his retirement his
bromance with mid laner Phoenix so good
guys so good and one heck of an ending
just go man just come in they're coming
they're coming
maybe
this is one to remember
more than just being the best anivia
player in the game echo Fox's froggen is
also a savvy strategist and in our
number six mic check we see just that
after Dignitas pushed echo fox out of
their base the danish veteran saw the
perfect opportunity coaching his
teammates big and Keith to run through
the jungle and go for a back door back
door you go in here go in here that you
need to hide it back though
going up backdoor it's pretty epic
[Applause]
so they can do it you know
dummy
while this game was basically a stop for
fnatic this particular episode of Mike
check deserves a spot at number five if
only for yellow star chanting kDa as he
encourages his teammates to kill
forgiven
even as they're knocking down as Ches
Nexus while Western team comms are often
characterized by shouting and repeating
the name of a champion until it's dead
Eastern teams have a much calmer style
vomits Angelo I next ironically kilala
[Applause]
few examples are better than our
number-four Mic Check from the deciding
game five of the 2015 midseason
Invitational Barista started a little
patient
I don't even as EDG bore down on s
Katie's Nexus and dealt them one of
their few defeats in a major tournament
they took it gracefully
EDG were a little less graceful and
victory but who can blame them after
taking down Goliath as a bonus we even
got insights into the fateful pic of
LeBlanc by SKT and edy G's delighted
reactions
[Music]
our number three pick is the double
dosage of mic check from the 2015
all-star event not only is it
interesting seeing plays from both sides
you also get to hear the trash talk
between players and 2-1-1 a swan
tournament I Boyd versus Monza ha oh
really
yep I have 100% win rate so you know
cure while both episodes are great our
fav has got to be team fires not only
for the famous snowball moments between
froggen and doublelift what the hell you
want snowball got hook up to change dude
you showing me like they won't be
standing in the right coat
OOP
but for faker shaking his head at his
own team's cheese the casters versus
pros TRO match from the 2015 midseason
Invitational takes number two on our
list for pure hilarity one minute we
kill them right okay I want minute we
kill them sure the outcome was not
surprising but seeing your favorite
League personalities and pros messin
around like your friends on discord is
pretty amazing I love this there might
be no greater rivalry and league of
legends than TSM vs. CLG which is why
this looked back into the history of
that famous matchup from 2015 tops our
list not only does it feature double ifs
still wearing black and blue but it also
has dyrus on TSM just months before his
retirement
trying to Bubba Megan I can go in
[Applause]
nostalgia aside it's a great look at
different styles of shotcalling by both
team as well as some great one-liners
classic dyrus
and those were our picks for the top 10
mic checks and League of Legends for
links to the full videos check the
description and definitely let us know
what your favorite Mic Check moments are
in the comment section below
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]